[Musica]
[Applauso]
Grazie Buonasera a tutti Allora il tema
di questo Ted è il coraggio ma io in
maniera un po' come contrappasso ho
deciso di iniziare un po' dall'opposto
dalla paura dal terrore e ho iniziato
con questa citazione intitolato questo
speech qui chi non terrorizza si ammala
di terrore che è una una citazione una
citazione da una canzone di Fabrizio De
Andrè che si intitola il bombarolo e che
fa parte di questo album storia di un
impiegato storia di un impiegato è un
Concept album che racconta la storia di
un trentenne durante i moti del maggio
francese Maggio 1968 che decide di darsi
al terrorismo E cosa c'entra questo con
l'energia nucleare lo scopriremo presto
i moti del maggio 68 sconvolsero
parecchio la Francia al punto che in un
ci fu un momento in cui il presidente
Charles de Gaulle chiese che fossero
schierate le forze armate particolari
paracadutisti dell'esercito contro gli
studenti e gli operai che Manifestavano
ad opporsi a questa richiesta fu il
Ministro delle Forze Armate il ministro
degli eserciti di noi lo definiremo il
Ministro della Difesa che questo signore
qua si chiama piermasmer
la crisi del 68 non fu l'unica che Miss
mehmer dovrete affrontare nel corso
della sua carriera politica nel 1972
mesmer venne nominato primo ministro di
Francia e L'anno dopo dovette affrontare
una crisi molto importante la crisi
energetica del kit pure
un breve riassunto nel 1973 Siria Egitto
invadono Israele inizia la guerra del
kippur i paesi dell'opec produttori di
petrolio dichiarano l'embargo del
petrolio contro tutti i paesi che
sostenevano Israele Quindi tutti i paesi
in atto inclusa la Francia e anche
l'Italia questo diede origine è una
crisi energetica molto importante con i
prezzi dei carburanti stelle e i governi
che dovettero adottare misure di
austerity energetica anche in Italia in
quella circostanza mesmer decise che la
Francia non poteva più essere vittima di
una circostanza del genere che la
Francia doveva rendersi energeticamente
indipendente e gli chiesero come e lui
rispose con questa frase almeno gli
viene attribuita in Francia non abbiamo
il petrolio ma abbiamo le idee non si sa
se la frase sia vera fittizia ma
effettivamente L'idea c'era e l'idea era
la nuclearizzazione dell'energia
francese nel giro di
15 anni A partire dal 73 la Francia
costruì oltre 50 reattori nucleari buona
parte dei quali sono ancora in servizio
oggi
i primi entrarono in funzione tra il 77
e il 78 tra il 78 e il 87 quindi in
quella decina di anni la Francia
diminuisce la sua dipendenza dal
petrolio dai combustibili fossili
dell'86%. negli ultimi 40 anni la
Francia ha avuto le mi cittadini di
anidride carbonica più bassa del G7
ha avuto la metà delle emissioni
rispetto alla Germania parità di consumo
un sesto se consideriamo solo le
emissioni legate al settore elettrico
Poi uno dice il nucleare Ci mette troppo
tempo Vabbè
viene da chiedersi Come mai non abbia
pensato al pericolo del terrorismo visto
che aveva dovuto affrontarlo negli anni
in quelli che in Francia sono stati di
fatto gli anni di piombo Se non ha
pensato che le centrali non potessero
essere un obiettivo terroristico forse
sottovalutava i terroristi o forse
quando noi pensiamo a questa eventualità
tendiamo a saper valutare il pericolo
Per quale motivo un terrorista dovrebbe
attaccare una centrale nucleare Beh
secondo gli analisti le motivazioni
possibili sono tre provocare un
incidente radiologico quindi un disastro
nucleare rubare del materiale
radioattivo oppure sabotare l'impianto
fare in modo che non funzioni
Partiamo dalla prima motivazione e
cerchiamo di capire perché non sussiste
Mettiamoci nei panni di un terrorista
che vuole provocare un disastro
radiologico quindi insomma si crea un
commando di terroristi di Elite
perfettamente addestrati che riescono a
sopraffare le forze speciali messe a
protezione delle centrali nucleari e a
farsi strada all'interno dell'impianto
fino alla controllo home si trovano a
fare con questo ok e che non so voi però
io non saprei esattamente da dove
cominciare se volessi far partire un
incidente Tenete presente che
semplicemente premere due bottoni nel
nell'ordine sbagliato fa scattare le
procedure di emergenza al reattore si
spegne da solo si chiama scram ed è una
procedura che fin dagli anni 70 è
automatica in tutti i reattori
occidentali ovviamente a Chernobyl non
lo era e però noi Supponiamo anche che
il nostro terrorista che il nostro
commando terrorista contenga al suo
interno un qualcuno addestrato ad
operare con i reattori nucleari
e che in qualche modo questa persona
riesca con molta difficoltà a provocare
una fusione del nocciolo Ovviamente
questo non può succedere a reattore
acceso è impossibile oggi può però
succedere a reattore spento sfruttando
il calore di decadimento Spengo il
reattore e poi faccio saltare tutti i
sistemi di raffreddamento Ci vuole un
po' di tempo perché oggi esistono quelle
Esiste il concetto di raffreddamento
passivo e quindi per almeno 72 ore il
calore viene asportato in maniera
naturale dal daimoti convettivi i
reattori più moderni hanno anche
ulteriori sistemi di sicurezza passivi
che fanno sì che il calore venga
asportato Per diverse settimane e in
tutto questo tempo si suppone che i
terroristi debbano mantenere il
controllo di una centrale nucleare con
contro un esercito che verrebbe
evidentemente mobilitato contro di loro
ma Supponiamo pure che possa succedere
c'è un problema anche una volta che il
nocciolo si è fuso le radiazioni non
sono uscite dalla centrale restano
contenute all'interno di quello che si
chiama
edificio di contenimento che sono degli
edifici caratterizzati dal fatto di
essere
piuttosto resistenti
Vediamo se parte il video
ok
Questo è un camion
Come vedete non
funziona molto bene ecco Però magari
siamo più fortunati possiamo lanciarci
contro un missile
Vediamo cosa succede lanciando un
missile contro un contenitore di rifiuti
radioattivi sicuramente fare un sacco di
danno vediamo al rallenty
neanche stavolta beh ma noi sappiamo che
i terroristi si sono fatti più
sofisticati negli ultimi anni hanno
imparato a utilizzare
gli aerei purtroppo come armi quindi
Vediamo cosa succede con un aereo
Possiamo vederlo meglio al rallenty
Ecco potete capire perché finora non si
è mai verificato un attentato a una
centrale nucleare Con lo scopo di
procurare un incidente radiologico il
secondo scopo con cui un terrorista
potrebbe attaccare una centrale nucleare
quello di rubare del materiale nucleare
rubare l'uranio E perché dovrebbe rubare
l'uranio Beh la prima motivazione che
può venire in mente è per farci una
bomba ma c'è un problema per fare una
bomba serve uranio arricchito almeno al
90%, meglio se 95%, e invece quello che
si trova all'interno di un reattore è
arricchito al 5 per cento Quindi se io
ho accesso ho rubato del materiale
nucleare per poterlo trasformare in
materiale utile per una bomba devo prima
di tutto convertirlo in esafloruro di
Uranio che è un gas a quel punto posso
poi arricchi metterlo in una centrifuga
gas che separa gli isotopi e una volta
che l'ho fatto potrò procedere con la
fabbricazione del mio combustibile del
mio materiale nucleare quindi non mi
basta rubare del materiale nucleare mi
servono effettivamente un centro di
conversione del materiale nucleare e un
centro di arricchimento con le
centrifughe a gas e però se ho a
disposizione un centro di conversione un
centro di arricchimento non ho bisogno
di rubare il materiale nucleare da una
centrale nucleare perché Posso
semplicemente comprare l'uranio estratto
da una miniera non ho nessun bisogno di
prendermi un rischio inutile Quindi
anche questo effettivamente non è un
gran piano e allora qualcuno dirà Beh ma
possono sempre rubare il materiale
nucleare per fare una bomba sporca cioè
accoppiare materiale radioattivo con un
esplosivo tradizionale che sparge questo
materiale radioattivo in giro ed è vero
possono farlo Ma per una cosa del genere
non serve rubare il materiale da una
centrale nucleare lo si può rubare da un
ospedale che tendenzialmente è meno
protetto di una centrale nucleare
ultima cosa ma non proprio ultima
trasportare in giro del materiale
radioattivo non è proprio semplicissimo
perché c'è qualcosa che noi umani siamo
davvero davvero bravi a fare e rivelare
le radiazioni oggi noi disponiamo di
detector che possono rivelare una radio
sorgente schermata e mascherata a 20
metri in 5 secondi sono in dotazione
alle forze armate alle polizia di
frontiera di tutto il mondo tanto che
esistono dei progetti per la
salvaguardia di alcune specie animali
come il rinoceronti che si basano
proprio sull'iniettare un radioisotopo
all'interno del Corno del rinoceronte
sapete che i corni di rinoceronti sono
oggetto di contrabbando
Ma se il Corner radioattivo diventa
molto più facile rivelarlo quando questo
viene portato attraverso un confine
Questo progetto si chiama raisotop e
come dire trovate più informazioni sul
loro sito internet Ovviamente la
presenza del radio isotopo non è
minimamente pericolosa per il
rinoceronte stesso
e infatti finora non si è mai verificato
un tentativo di attacco una centrale
nucleare Con lo scopo di rubare del
materiale nucleare Non resta che la
terza motivazione quindi quella di
sabotaggio E effettivamente degli
attentati degli attacchi alle centrali
nucleari di questo tipo nella storia
sono avvenuti quasi tutti adopera di
movimenti ambientalisti o comunque di
movimenti politici contrari alle
centrali nucleari il primo di cui si
notizia è avvenuto nel 1973 alla
centrale di atuccia in Argentina la
centrale non era ancora operativa
stavano finendo i lavori un gruppo di
guerriglieri è entrato ha fatto
irruzione ha rubato le armi del
contingente che protegge il cantiere ha
scritto dei graffiti sui muri e se n'è
andato
Il secondo è successo in Francia a
brannes dove un gruppo di separatisti
bretoni
ha tagliato la ringhiera di una centrale
Insomma della recinto di una centrale
nucleare si è fatto strada all'interno e
ha messo una bomba nei Condotti che
aspiravano l'acqua di raffreddamento il
reattore è andato in arresto di
emergenza e il danno è stato riparato la
centrale ha ripreso a funzionare senza
alcun tipo di problema
nel 1977 un gruppo ambientalista messo
una bomba Presso la centrale di in
Oregon una bomba presso il Centro
visitatori era molto lontana dal
reattore Ma avrebbe potuto ovviamente
far male a qualcuno per fortuna ha detto
no Senza fare morti o feriti
una cosa simile successe due volte in
Svizzera nel 79 a Kaiser August e
agusgen sicuramente la centrale che ha
subito più attacchi di tutti è quella di
lemoniz in Spagna la centrale di lemonis
non è mai stata terminata O meglio non è
mai stata entrata in funzione Perché
Perché si trovano i Paesi Baschi ed è
stata costruita durante Gli anni d'oro
del terrorismo basco dell'età nel 1977
venne messa la prima bomba per fortuna
scoppiò senza conseguenze nel 79 ne
vennero messe altre due una uccise due
operai l'altra uccise un operaio
la centrale venne poi effetti i lavori
della centrale terminarono nell'82 però
le tarapì e dopo una settimana assassinò
il direttore della centrale nucleare
Allora Pino nella Centrale Europea casa
sua e poi lo uccisero e nell'83 fecero
la stessa cosa con la persona che era
succeduta a questo direttore quindi fu
rapito e assassinato
nell'83 le ci furono le elezioni e il
governo spagnolo il nuovo governo
spagnolo decise di fermare il progetto
della centrale nucleare di lemonitz che
tutt'oggi No aspettate
Ok tuttora la centrale di lemon inizia
in Spagna è terminata non è mai stata
accesa la vedete in foto Quelli sono due
reattori nucleari ad acqua pressurizzata
Da 900 MB ciascuna la centrale Però non
è stata mai accesa e lì finita e mai
entrata in operazione un po' uno spreco
invece
l'attentato più eclatante contro una
centrale nucleare avvenne nel 1982 in
Francia al reattore super Fenix super
Fenix era la filiera francese che doveva
chiudere il ciclo del combustibile
nucleare con i reattori veloci al sodio
il reattore super Fenix era ancora in
costruzione e venne attaccato da
quest'uomo quest'uomo si chiama Acciai
missim di origini israeliane
e si definiva un militante Eco pacifista
E infatti Siccome era pacifista attaccò
il reattore nucleare con un
lanciagranate RPG 5 ottenuto dalla Raf
la banda mather mineoff tedesca per
gentile e intercessione di Carlos de
Jackal uno dei terroristi più ricercati
degli anni 70
mistem sparo cinque colpi di
lanciagranate contro il muro di
contenimento senza creare particolare
danno due anni do tre anni dopo nel 85
venne eletto parlamentare per il partito
dei verdi nel parlamento cantonale di
Ginevra solo nel 2003 ammise di essere
stato lui l'autore dell'attacco Cioè non
lo hanno candidato sapendo che era un
terrorista Almeno quello
è morto mi sembra nel 2007
e successivamente
un altro attacco bomba fu effettuato
alla centrale di batana nelle Filippine
da guerriglieri comunisti il
la centrale venne poi la ricostruzione
della centrale venne fermata e tuttora
incompleta solo adesso si sta parlando
di ricominciare a riprendere il progetto
vi sono poi stati degli attentati negli
Stati Uniti nel 86 hanno tagliato i cavi
dell'Elettricità che portavano alla
centrale di Palo verde
mentre nel
87 hanno messo una bomba in California
nel parcheggio di un centro di ricerca
nucleare Per fortuna la detonazione
avvenne in anticipo quindi saltare in
aria due macchine ma non c'era nessuno a
bordo dal 87 oggi gli attentati nelle
centrali nucleari sono stati più che
altro azioni dimostrative di gruppi
ambientalisti soprattutto Greenpeace che
ogni tanto entrano nei cancelli della
centrale nucleare mettono uno striscione
aspettano che la polizia venga ad
arrestarli quindi sono manifestazioni
pacifiche e innocue Comunque sempre
meglio che le linee di Nazca
e in conclusione che cosa possiamo dire
Beh l'esperienza ci insegna che il
pericolo di un attacco terroristico e
una centrale nucleare in realtà è
piuttosto basso il film di James Bond in
cui 007 deve salvare il mondo dai
cattivi che hanno preso in ostaggio una
centrale nucleare probabilmente sarebbe
molto breve e si svolgerebbe all'incirca
in questo modo
m sono Bond ho fatto irruzione nella
centrale sono riuscito a arrivare nella
sala di controllo
ottimo lavoro 007 Dovresti vedere un
pulsante rosso
ne vedo almeno una dozzina
molto bene prendine uno uno qualsiasi
fatto e adesso
hai finito puoi andare a vedere se nella
mensa della centrale fanno il Vodka
Martini
Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]